in this video we're going to talk about
how to solve quadratic equations by
taking square roots so this is called
sometimes the square root method and
when you solve quadratic equations
there's many other methods like the
quadratic formula or factoring or
graphing or completing the square but in
this square root method I'm going to
show you two different examples that you
might come across and the idea here is
that you have a perfect square see how
we have x squared or some type of
quantity squared that's what we want to
isolate we want to get by itself on one
side of the equal side now notice in
this problem that we have a squared term
but we don't have like an x to the first
term like a linear term we just have
this quadratic or second degree term so
let's work from the outside in towards
that x squared to get it by itself on
one side of the equation so I'm going to
do that by adding 1 to both sides
you don't want to multiply by 3 first
you want to work from the outside in so
that's going to give us 27 the 1 and the
negative 1 cancel and now we're down to
x squared divided by 3. of course the
opposite of dividing by 3 is just to
multiply both sides by three it's just
like solving a regular algebra equation
right Algebra 1 and we have now x
squared is equal to 81.
now that we've got this quadratic by
itself all we have to do is do the
opposite or the inverse I should say
instead of squaring you want to take the
square root of both sides to keep it
balanced
but remember when you take the square
root of both sides you get two answers
you get a positive or A negative so the
square root of 81 is 9 but we're going
to say that our answer is positive or
negative 9. it's both those Solutions
now for number two we have this quantity
this binomial of two terms squared so
we're going to try to isolate and get
just this perfect square here by itself
on one side of the equal sign again
working from the outside in towards that
perfect square the minus 6 is further
away so I'm going to add that 6. to both
sides to give us 30 on the right
and now we're just left with 5 times X
plus 2 squared on the left again still
working in towards this perfect square
here we're going to divide both sides by
5.
and so now we're left with X plus 2 the
quantity squared is equal to 30 divided
by 5 which is 6. now that we have this
perfect square by itself instead of
squaring let's take the square root of
both sides the square and the square
root those undo one another they cancel
each other out and you just have X plus
2 equals again remember that plus or
minus square root of 6. now some
teachers will have you split this into
two equations okay and what you can do
is you can solve x plus 2 is equal to
positive Root 6 and X plus two is equal
to negative root 6. here we're just
going to subtract 2 from both sides same
thing here subtract two from both sides
so we get x equals negative 2 plus
square root of 6 over here we get x
equals negative 2 minus square root of
6.
and those are your two solutions now
another way to do this you can subtract
two but when you do that make sure you
subtract 2 in front of that plus or
minus or to the left of that plus or
minus sign and you're going to get these
same two answers
so great job if you're able to follow
these two examples if you want to see
all the five different techniques that
are used to solve quadratic equations
follow me over to that video I did right
there to learn all those other different
techniques I'll see you in that video